yeah okay we're doing breaking security
[ __ ] wedding well good to fight
alongside you hey cap betcha brother
I've been waiting for you your next
contract away as I'm sure Astrid
indicated with the Emperor's arrival in
Skyrim security you ya later commander
son Gaius maro and once he's dead he
essentially go there now once he's dead
plant the incriminating letter on his
body and let fate take care of the rest
sure sure and one final thing to earn
your bonus do not kill Gaius maro and
dragon bridge or on the road kill him in
one of the other major cities will be
visiting their the body will be
discovered quickly as with a letter
indicating Gaius maro in the plot to
assassinate the Emperor
tucked Adams coming Allen being Armani
did I just kind of can tap that
[Music]
gimme some of that breaking back get it
cut off i'll get one of the more horses
then I ride back you know what I'm
saying here's a horse a decline to get
Skyrim in her people I'll see you in
your defense all right all right keep
your voice down don't let me catch I
can't tell which way to go that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] horses mentally challenged
yes slam yeah I guess I can that's good
heading here by say here here
a lot of speed up the horse is like yeah
it does game and Callen hello you picked
a bad time to get lost friend and one
that's all I don't know if this [ __ ]
heels like my guys help not come back oh
wait there we go
um father can worry too much all the
things remember everything said stay
alone think I was like yeah like don't
write down [ __ ] attack them right at
all of it place incriminating letter on
him and how do I do that [ __ ] that
how do I
ok
you can see now except the horse is
[ __ ] amazing but one of my items not
ah [ __ ] 27 pipe all this [ __ ] 35
aren't the horse comes with me I don't
know good night down now
I wish I had these answers for you but I
just thought I don't got sorry Anna Wow
I'd love I've been anxiously awaiting
your return I know God does Astrid and
you